Phils take game one of the championship
series Welcome to The Closer on TBS
presented by Genesis Jimmy playing it
off like he wasn't nervous with a runner
on in the ninth welcome inside CM cool
out I got a Phillies MVP three-time
Allstar Curtis Granderson Albert phol
with us one of the best to ever do it
the Hall of Famer Pedro Martinez my name
is Lauren shahadi Philly's ambushed
early Arizona never recovered I mean
watching home run after home run with a
guy who hit 703 you were like a kid the
Phil he got pop Albert that's all
they've been doing this playoffs you
know I mean they just send a message
right away from that first interview you
got Bryce Harper you know and sherber
just went deep you know and when you
have the Ace in the mound that's what
you want to do run support right away in
that first inning kind of keep that
energy that were in that ballpark you
know and that's how it was the first
five innings I mean it was electric it
was really electric Pedro you're trying
to settle in on the mountain how can you
get that Phillies lineup no way you
don't they did they did not give him a
chance to set up anything and plus uh on
my own feeling I I don't think he had
the command of the fast ball especially
early it's different when you're
pitching a dome and you you know what
kind of temperature you're going to
expect the humidity you know how to get
your body going but when you're in the
open especially when it's chiler in in
Philadelphia than it is in Arizona or
anywhere else uh you have to wait for
your body to respond to the things that
you're used to doing from one leadoff
hitter to another K schwarber is
incredible love it I wouldn't consider
him a leadoff hitter I know right he's a
lead off he's a leadoff home run hitter
they come in all different forms these
days don't they and they really do and
it works for them they they believe the
that this is the way for them to win and
it has worked and what we're seeing is
kind like their August they had a record
set in August where they come out hit
home run after home run and when these
guys get hot it can last for a long time
and all they need is to be hot for a
couple more weeks oh here we go you know
with have prayed down Broad Street
that's right it's not just one through
four in that lineup Curtis it's not one
through four it's the stands it's the
fans it's the bottom of the lineup
Albert talked about energy that second
home run by Bryce do you see him jumping
like they going come through the TV
Jimmy you talked about it shaking there
in the bank I think we felt it watching
it here at home that's the energy that
you want to see and feel and they gave
it to him from the first pitch of the
game and kept it going all game what I
liked I'm sorry it's the Pelos when they
were on they were talking like
oh that was I did it too but I like
watching their reactions they were in
the middle of a conversation all of a
sudden boom we were trying to settle in
our seat and eat our Donuts right and
there was action early tomorrow's game
same time same place we will take you
there at 700 p.m. eastern time and get
you to the bank for first pitch at 8:00
p.m. on TBS Diamondbacks came into this
game gentlemen without a loss this month
the Phillies only lost once to the
Braves how about these first pitches Don
Staley Jay Wright throwing out the very
first pitch Travis and Jason Kelsey
taken in this one on Bryce Harper's
birthday I saw the Philly Social account
say he was born in October and for
October I'm stealing it love having
impact on the game and that is what the
Philadelphia fans always do Kyle
schwarber for
Ste very first pitch of the game Ambush
City from Zack gallon off the facade
second deck in right for lead off Homer
and then two batters later fourth player
in postseason history to hit home run on
his birthday and just watch the fans
just jumping up and down literally
making the place shaking Rock we got a
little man behind home plate with all
that drip on his neck got to get caller
Pedro what is that petting that's a ding
dong Johnson in the post SE nice and
cool
one I'm loving it bottom of the second
how do you feel about opposite field
nick castios uh loves it off the
question mark just
answered in his last three games he is
scorching hot think he's having fun
Beautiful s swing what do you got on
that swing ap5 staying through man let
that ball get deep I mean he's hot he's
swinging riding man loving it hit
nothing Philadelphia before you know it
need a little cushion in October nobody
knows that more than this guy Bryce
Harper hard single into right field Trey
Turner don't mind if I do but Pedro we
talked about a base open right there you
said it in the show yeah but the thing
is I think they did a great homework on
Gallen they knew he couldn't spot the
Fastow so they eliminated the Fastow and
started looking for the breaking stop
off over the plate and they got him big
spot base is loaded 643 I think watching
the game the whole game you know what
you seeing was the opposite Philadelphia
Philly just came hot and hit first pitch
you know you see those homers they were
on first pitch when in the other side
the Diamond Back were kind of taking
especially the first couple of innings a
lot of strike from Zack Wheeler and when
you have a guy in the M like that you
better swing him because if you don't
swing you feel like 0 and two all the
time so they were giving him first pish
down the middle and you know he did his
thing punch out way guys absolute magic
set down 15 straight Arizona hitters
Diamond Backs looking alive haraldo Pomo
pulls the Zack Wheeler fast ball over
the wall on the right that's a two-run
shot and they were chipping away that's
what they've done all year but Zach
wheeler really never let them kind of
get in a Groove this dude Jose Alvarado
tying run at the plate what a moment in
time and they had chances throughout the
whole game even though they were down
five nothing they just kept slowly
putting pressure slowly having
opportunities and just couldn't get that
extra run to come across where did you
have that pitch it was down okay it was
down but you know you got to understand
what was happening okay Kimbrell has
been doing it at a very high level for a
very long time double play turn two and
that is your ball game GRE Kimbrell
relieved and happy so the Phillies jump
on Arizona early and often they take
game one of the NLCS behind a gem from
Zack Wheeler game two tomorrow Meo Kelly
and Aaron Nola sharing the mound Jimmy
Rollins we love you but we got to keep
you humble are you ready before today
you listen to me you and Derek Jeter
were tied for the most spe off home runs
in the postseason not any more Kyle
schwarber has four and honestly some of
them should count for two I mean you
know what if we're going to lose it to
anybody a guy like schwarber and that
Philly uniform I'm perfectly okay with
it now in another uniform no but in that
Philly uniform go ahead keep on pressing
on what did we say in the pregame show
we said do not Pitch to Bryce Harper in
the 2011 World Series against what was
Texas yeah you walked six times five
times intentionally how many times were
you hit by a pitch I don't know like
three or four times probably three or
four times count they just said you're
not going to beat us and that's what
they do with Bryce Harper but Pedro the
problem is there are so many other guys
who can hurt you in that lineup what are
you doing yeah I I just I just wanted
you to see that I was doing my homework
okay and that's what they should have
done just like Philadelphia did it on
gallin gallin got ambushed why because
sometimes uh being on the strike zone
too often and and it did happen to me
especially late in my career I'll get
ambushed because people knew I was going
to throw strikes Philadelphia knew that
gin normally relies on his fast ball to
set up the rest of the stuff and Pitch
off the fast ball the only difference is
the and and the elements probably
affected gin little bit when it comes to
feeling for the fast ball because late
in the game it seems like he had a
better Rhythm it seemed like he was
starting to pick up what he wanted to do
but it took him a while to get his body
going and to get the feel for the fastb
he had the breaking stuff around but
couldn't implement it early in the game
and the Philadelphia feel is not only
are they aggressive but they know what
they're hunting for see those are fast B
fast ball middle middle of the
play th High I mean
Harper Castellanos and those guys they
not going to be missing those and they
didn't and the
results you you got them right there
look look at this look at this count
right
here look what they're doing they're
just eliminating some and taking
what Gallen is going to give them right
there look that's another situation
since you eliminate the fast ball you
can always Center Middle in anything
breaking pretty much at the same speed
change up cutter slider so you you
you're off the number one the number one
is the one that sets up everything else
and that's the one that makes the
biggest difference between speeds and
between pitches is the number one and he
could not spot it all night and ended up
costing him uh the lead of the game
early yeah but you know what you had to
give him some credit because the way
that this game started you never thought
that he was going to have throw five in
six in how he did no without a doubt
without a doubt what he did goes beyond
what the results show because it allowed
lulo to set up his Bullpen the way he
wanted not only for today's game but for
the rest of the series I think his
Bullpen is in is in good shape and I
think what Gallen did for for Tor lulo
today and his team is a lot more
valuable than people can see why because
not only did he allow his team to
actually stay in the game but also give
them the opportunity to kind of save
some bullets for the next day in the
next two games that they're going to be
playing against the Phillies because
believe me uh I don't think that there's
any way that that offense from
Philadelphia is going to be uh stopped
and limit to just three four runs and
sometimes five I think there's going to
be fire uh from both teams yeah he did a
good job and and on the other side of
that Philly did what exactly what they
were supposed to as a leadoff hitter is
all as you say as you go they go schwarb
went he captured that energy as Curtis
gave gave credit to and was the reason
why when I hit lead off especially in
the playoffs I want to be aggressive
because why pitchers don't want to go
one0 they're trying to go 01 it's going
to be fast ball not a lot of movement
and it is the best pitch you're probably
going to hit that night especially if
you have any pop you get out there you
don't give him a chance to get
comfortable to get to a secondary
pitches he throw a strike one okay let
me feel what's next it's one nothing now
he's starting all over again now where
do I go to next he gets the next guy
Bryce comes up trying to get ahead again
it's two nothing he didn't have a chance
to settle in early and he captured that
energy and Wheeler who's been there in
he Enon he went out there dominated with
the lead two runs in the playoffs is
almost as good as four it seems like it
they have to scor three Le that's and
you as you say get you two you're not
giving up three and that's that's most
most of the time I wouldn't and I feel
like disappointed by the way which is
super no I I I didn't pitch four three
in my entire career
such interesting perspective in Tory
lello Diamond Back Skipper talked about
gallon getting ambushed postgame here's
what he had to say listen
this uh you know I think they just
ambushed him I think they they came out
um ready to jump on his fast ball
there's no mystery that Zach fills up
the Zone he's got he's got aggressive
fast ball an aggressive mindset and they
just they just counter punched him um
you know I
think the I I don't think he was trying
to throw the pitches where where they
landed had a chance to look at him but I
know when Zach gets squared up it's
usually uh you know a couple inch
mistake he's that good at hitting lines
when he's trying to throw pitches in
certain spots I think they just ambushed
a couple mistakes and never really got
into a rhythm um you know I felt like
there were points in time that he was
making pitches and was going to start
toing or start to take a Zack gallon
type of um start to look like a Zach
gallon outing but it never really
happened um and it was just just a big
grind for him the whole
day I mean all the Phillies can hurt you
Curtis some more than others 368 500 no
thank you but they keep saying Ambush I
mean it wasn't Ambush it was the game
plan that Philadelphia had I mean that
that's it you know they went in with the
plan this is what we had that's why you
got The Scouting Report and they execute
that's that's it you know and you
overheard uh Bryce talk about it in his
interview he said we know he throws
every pitch for strike had Kevin long as
a hitting coach one of the things I
would always ask him before the game
does the pitcher throw strikes if the
answer was yes okay we know we have to
be aggressive why fall behind like you
said I pitcher don't want to be one they
want to be 01 and when these pitchers
are 01 that's when they're at their best
so when they all know collectively that
the opposition throws strikes and we can
be aggressive where we want to be that's
a game plan like you talking about it's
not necessar Ambush he's throwing strike
one be ready to swing on strike one and
that was a plan from top to bot and let
me add something to that if his strikes
like wheeler was throwing at 96 to 97 98
mil an hour it's a different strike but
when you have 92 to 94 and and you
throwing it in the strike zone and and
you don't command your fastball as good
as you normally do you're in for trouble
I mean they got nothing to do but to go
out there and take a mighty hack because
they're not intimidated by the 92 to 94
miles hour fast ball then they know you
don't have it so most likely you're
going to try to throw strike with
anything that breaks around and they
they they know how to hit those and and
especially if you don't have the number
one to kind of stablish everything else
can we start talking about Zach wheeler
as one of the best in the game I'm not
talking about top 20 in the game it's a
different tier an 18 to1 strikeout to
walk ratio 18 to1 he was nasty the four
steam are working 24 of his first 31
fast balls were strike I mean I've
learned my lesson you're sitting fast
balls it's tough to see it it definitely
is and and as Pedro said there there's a
difference between 92 to 94 and a guy
who can touch 100 he throw you know he's
he's talking about his length how when
he releases the ball he's a little
closer to a little further out front
than you know a 6' three pitcher on top
of that when he gets that Back Spin you
see the ball at your waist but about the
time he gets to the plate it's actually
where it really is above the waist so
you swing and and missing out a lot of
it then he has a big sweeping curveball
that you have to be aware of so some
guys they can 100 and there's nothing to
it he throws 97 96 to 98 with movement
on top of that being closer to you with
the big breaking ball it is a tough task
to go out there and when he's on he is
on I mean I got the face young Zack
before he got nasty I'm thankful for
that because what he's doing now I
that's why I'm retired and you talked
about like you're retired now you're
hanging out with us and Pedro you talked
about different fast balls like we saw
Corbin Carroll swing at the first pitch
was he trying trying to Ambush possibly
but he swung right through it he got a
hit but it was a broken bad hit so it's
one thing to say we're going to be
aggressive I think they were trying to
be aggressive against Wheeler They just
couldn't because he had a different fast
ball like you're talking and not only
that he was able to locate his fast ball
he had a the perfect plan for the
Arizona Diamond bats and it looked to me
on Perdomo hit that ball and that wasn't
a bad pitch was a pitch that was middle
in up in the strike zone got his so you
tip your hat to that but before that
everybody looked like undressed on the
plate and that includes Carol Carol had
that head that broken B head but they
had no idea how to approach wheeler the
entire time wheeler had a game plan
against those guys and their stuff to do
it like I have never seen uh so far in
in the postseason they went and got on
kersha they they got on everybody
including Milwaukee topnotch ping they
got to them but this time it's like they
Willer undressed them all and they had
no idea how they were naked right on top
of the plate they were naked same par
naked in the cold
too comination we did we get paid for
more coffee
tonight we need